are you taking Chandler's nest last name
are you bindi Powell now are you
sticking with bindi Irwin
I have kept indeed hours I think that
for me last night you know after after
dad passed away this really important
for you to look close to having so much
to me I'd have pronounce you husband and
wife
Chandler
[Music]
bhindi and Chandler the newlyweds thank
you for joining us on ET you're two
months in how is newlywed life first of
all it is amazing to have gotten there
it appears so grateful to take on this
new era as a very couple but it has been
a really funny time we have spent our
honeymoon here at Australia Zoo caring
for 1,200 animals
shortly after we got married soon to
temporarily close which was unbelievable
to everything and our hearts go out and
we've been filming at all - so I think
it's an urban family tradition to get
married and terian seed went up and call
crocodiles or the film crew and we're
here at the zoo with the film crew it's
true
mom and dad's honeymoon was spent
catching Crocs with an entire film crew
so you know we tried to set the bar even
higher you couldn't be more on brand I
have to ask you did you have a different
honeymoon planned was there a trip that
you had to scrap back because I'm
originally from Florida we plan to do a
honeymoon road trip seeing the best
sights of Australia's are going to
central desert going down to Tasmania
and back quickly changed it's funny
originally Robert had said my amazing
brother he had said that when they don't
have honeymoon that he was just gonna
tag along and we all had a really good
love and Robert have been every day
and so is the rest of the world those
faces so many challenges that we
consider ourselves very healthy and safe
in a beautiful part of the world doing
the best we can to keep our you used to
calling each other husband and wife yet
it's so special you know
we always say we feel like we've been
married three years but to finally
officially have a ring on our fingers it
is so cool are you taking Chandler's
nest last name are you bindi Powell now
or are you sticking with bindi Irwin
it's a really good question I kept in
deep hours I think that for me
personally you know after after dad
passed away is really important to the
course I think that for us sharing
cockys totally will both always have our
parties on yeah we talked about it a lot
and the next thing is that it's 2020
yeah so anything work is incredibly
special day and of course everybody
could give you
and we love so much because of the
current global crisis what was it like
for you emotionally to have to shelve
the plans that you'd been working on for
quite a while and readjust yeah first of
all I have to say you handle it I mean
you always hear stories of brides kind
of panicking when little things go wrong
I think everything went different to
plan with our wedding but you handled it
so well I kept checking in on Fendi
whenever there's a slight change saying
are you all good and every times like no
well just roll with it at the end of the
day briquette that's the important thing
so personal thank you for being such an
amazing house the most common everything
gonna be our tank but it was crazy first
and foremost we wanted to make sure that
everyone's home safety was the priority
so whatever so we made that decision not
to have any guests at our wedding to
make sure everyone was safe we had to
change the actual date of our wedding
day so we were going to get married on
everything was just getting too hectic
okay Chandler's family were incredible
for them to be able to and that gave us
that yeah because they're all in Florida
so having their support meant the world
and even though they weren't there on
the day they were definitely celebrating
or they were so happy and we out to walk
down that aisle be funny about African
savannah and suddenly a media helicopter
flew over all of us and started blowing
everything away
and terrifying all of our animals they
were babies and giraffes and everyone
was running around and so we had to
entirely shift our wedding ceremony
times we were about to get married so we
changed all of that
and I never before I was in my wedding
dress we found we found this one of our
beautiful Chabad the jungle and I went
this is gonna work it's inside our
animals would you say to helicopter and
I was there my wedding just putting up
flowers and routing tables trying to
make it back and we somehow got married
it may not have been a traditional
wedding and normal it was not and that's
the reality of life you know life is is
messy and crazy and filled with
obstacles and what an incredible
foundation - thanks apologizes are
becoming anything and just focusing on
whoa do you have plans to when you can
go on a honeymoon or or have a party and
then that kind of thing definitely so
we've been calling my family in Florida
a whole lot just reveling in the
excitement but we definitely are
planning something as soon as the world
settles down and everyone is safe
visiting my family and having there's a
reception or a backyard cookout just
celebrating with them just to keep the
wedding happiness going I promise to be
your strength and your like when you
needed my husband my teammate and my
partner in conservation bindi you were
tearing up when you were saying your
vows to Chandler what was hitting you in
that moment that emotion just planet
comes at you like a freight train and I
think it was a lip so pure joy and
feeling the weight of everything you've
gone through
it's it's a mix of emotions and you see
people that could do that whether it was
because of the pandemic kind of looking
the rest now in the box
Jen decided to tear up a little bit when
he was giving
yeah when he cuz he doesn't usually get
super emotional I think when I watched
Shane's not to get emotional I just when
you're in the moment with the person you
love
it just all overcomes you and almost
just feels like a dream well you guys
you still managed to have all those
beautiful traditions the cake and and
you looked like you had a dance what was
your wedding song did you have one I
know you love to dance bendy it's sure
actually it was here comes the Sun we
wax our had the night before because we
we didn't know what we were gonna do so
the night before we wake up tomorrow and
just died and so the night before you
didn't have any clue what the plan was
it was about 10:00 p.m. the night before
and we got a wedding together in about
14 hours for the next day with mum when
prophet and we just all were talking and
I went the well this changes so much we
need to just get married and so we just
decided at 10 p.m. that night that the
next day we get married
so quite literally what polling people
going hey you do you have a wedding cake
I called my wedding dress wasn't even
ready yet cool the beautiful women and
said can you please leave them help me
and fit the dress to me babe try to do
like an hour just to get the dress
fitted last minute yeah it was it was
phenomenal I said I said on the phone I
I'll go to the grocery store and buy all
their flowers I will be people that
couldn't be here because they're
watching over them and there are guiding
lights and this candle is to represent
dad when you lit that candle for him and
had the photo of him there how did you
choose that photo why is that one so
special
oh I love that dude so much just
probably one of his beautiful see and I
got my middle name
she's always held a special place in my
heart and growing up she was one of the
very first I loved Chandler right I I
loved how you said that you know see was
the reason you were even standing there
because he was your childhood hero if he
had been able to be there in person what
would you have wanted to say to him on
that day
Wow you know I think the biggest thing I
would like to say it's just thank you on
behalf of the world and especially me
for inspiring my love of Wildlife
growing up in Florida we had alligators
and saints and turtles and watching the
seed documentaries in my khakis when I
was four years old really made me fall
in love with all forms of life so in a
way he brought us together because when
I came to Australia after watching his
documentaries I wanted to come visit
Australia Zoo and that was when we met
then he was giving me a tour of
Australia Zoo on that day the visit so
the biggest thing and I'd like to say
then is just thank you for inspiring my
passion in life and also bringing me and
Ben together because if it weren't for
him I don't know how we would've met you
know I've never asked you guys this
Chandler did you did you for lack of a
better term make a move that day did you
say hey can I get your email address how
did you guys go from a tour to now being
married exactly a really funny story so
I came to the zoo and coincidentally
bindi was giving tours that day and I
knew immediately this girl is doing
special I mean we just connected
immediately so I wanted to go about it
in a way that was respectful because we
became friends for
and then best friends and then finally
evolved into a relationship so I reached
out to then he threw my brother actually
writing a note to Australia Zoo and
Terry's saying okay I really had a great
time on the tour would it be okay if
Chandler kept in touch with Indy and I
think we swapped email addresses
initially and then finally phone numbers
[Music]